these children now grown up are speaking
out about an institution they believe to
this day is failing to protect young
people from predatory pedophiles and to
learn from mistakes of the past
emily who doesn't want to be identified
was sexually abused from the age of four
by a ministerial servant of the
jehovah's witnesses in loughborough
aged eight she reported it to church
elders those in charge of governing and
disciplining the congregation
at that point i had a conversation
i was very young and
sort of said i
don't like the way he touches me what
followed was a series of failings that
allowed him to continue sexually abusing
children for years to come which victims
say is a larger cultural problem within
the organization
there was a phrase they
used a lot which is liars will not
inherit god's kingdom
which is basically saying
you're going to die at armageddon
because you're a liar
speaking about jehovah became a
wonderful joy jehovah's witnesses have a
gentle image of those spreading the
faith but believe that only they will be
saved from imminent armageddon as
depicted here in their literature
there's a mistrust of non-believers and
it's one of the reasons why serious
allegations such as child abuse often
aren't taken to the police but instead
handled internally they had a similar
kind of meeting with him about it all
and
unbeknownst to me he actually admitted
it to them
and then after that they continued to
tell me that i'd misunderstood it
there was no
kind of reprimand for him i still had to
interact with him i actually got told
off for not sitting on his knee
the abuser peter stewart repented and
said there were no other victims when in
fact there were at least four others
including two sisters who are speaking
out together for the first time
because they believed him he was allowed
to continue in the congregation and my
abuse and my sister's abuse was allowed
to continue
amelia didn't report her abuse until
after he'd been jailed for abusing two
other children
when he came out of prison she tried to
stop him rejoining the congregation
they decided that they didn't believe me
because i didn't have a
a credible second witness and because
they have obviously the two witness rule
within the jehovah's witness church yes
the second person has to have seen what
happened they do and it's not just the
two witness rule
the second witness has to be a credible
witness
and at this point
your sister is the other witness is that
right that's correct yes
rachel the elder sister who was abused
first wishes she'd spoken out sooner i
wanted to protect her i wanted
you know i just wanted her
she was amazing to me like
and
what you felt like you let her down
because you hadn't
raised what was happening to you
yeah
i always thought that if i'd have said
that first time if i'd have spoken out
the first time
when he'd kissed me
um
it wouldn't happen to him
peter stewart did apologize for the
abuse in this letter to the girl's
mother but even then their testimony was
not trusted i mean from everything
you're saying to me it sounds like
the
the weight and gravitas of a known child
sex offender
is more worth more
than that of three women yes
emilia successfully sued the
organization for failing to protect her
rachel says they both could have been
saved years of pain had they have taken
note of that child that he admitted to
it wouldn't have
it just wouldn't i could have had a few
years
as a child
there are 130 000 jehovah's witness
members in england and wales with a
large central office campus in essex and
8.6 million members worldwide
if elders receive a complaint about
child abuse they will contact the head
office here in chelmsford and they will
consult their legal department as well
as this handbook shepherd the flock of
god
only elders can open and they are all
men with no external child protection
training
so what does the book tell them
well it reinforces much of what we've
already heard
eyewitnesses there must be two or three
eyewitnesses not just people repeating
hearsay
no action can be taken if there's only
one witness
what's missing is any urgent action to
protect child welfare you're not
encouraged to go to outside agencies you
won't be criticized for going to the
police but you're not actively told to
do so and if there isn't a second
witness well it seems that's where the
matter ends
jehovah's witnesses say the two witness
rule only relates to whether or not the
accused should potentially be expelled
from the religion rather than whether
they should be reported to the police
however the book suggests allegations
are sealed and kept in a confidential
file
one former jehovah's witness elder who
left the religion because of the way it
deals with child abuse believes the
police should be demanding access to
those records if it was say a gym
franchise or if it was say a public
school
and they were keeping records on
teachers or gym or gym members or gym
instructors
about these individuals being predators
and not passing these on to the police
these institutions would be all over our
front pages i like to think
in 2016 australian royal commission
investigators did obtain files that
jehovah's witnesses kept on allegations
of child abuse there they found of 1006
alleged sexual abusers none had been
reported to the police jehovah's
witnesses say any records they keep are
for the purposes of protecting children
lacey jones was abused from the age of
10 for over a decade by an elder in the
congregation in the west midlands when
confronted in 2019
clifford whitely confessed to other
elders to some of the abuse but lacey
has waived her anonymity to explain what
happened when she told them she was
going to the police the first thing they
said was it's your absolute right it's
your absolute right to go to the police
however what they don't tell you is that
they will not cooperate
she asked the elders why they wouldn't
hand over evidence from the confession
what was their reasoning for not helping
with the investigation
because creeper told them in confidence
but also
that in order to be able to talk to the
police they would need to step down from
their position as elders so i waited for
you know at least one to say therefore
i'll step down and whatever whatever
i'll say without the confession
nothing silence they didn't look at me
they were looking at the floor they were
looking at the ceiling
and i just said
but he's a paedophile
and again without looking at me they
just said
yeah we know
police eventually got a record of the
confession via a warrant and whiteley
was jailed for nine years in 2020.
suppose that someone is convicted and
put in jail
well that would apply to this is one of
the messages to the flock telling them
only to seek truth from elders warning
them not to believe negative reports
about the church in the media not even
if someone is jailed for a crime
or someone is found guilty
by men as jesus was
it doesn't mean that he's guilty
in the sight of god
so brothers we really have to think
about these things
all four women we spoke to believe the
organization's leaders put protecting
its reputation ahead of protecting
children and that the religion's
distrust of non-believers allows them to
keep doing that
they kind of i suppose
almost put themselves on a pedestal they
call their religion the truth and they
are
the only ones that have got the correct
religion and everything else is just
incorrect you're in like a bubble like
you
don't really have any interactions with
the outside world
with
general stuff and actually
people that aren't part of that religion
are called
worldly and you're discouraged from
having anything to do with them
in a statement the organization said
when elders learn that someone in the
congregation is accused of child sexual
abuse they immediately take steps to
ensure the matter is reported to the
external secular authorities as may be
required by law or if it appears that a
child may be in danger of abuse
elders do not shield a perpetrator from
the legal consequences of his sin do not
interfere with law enforcement and leave
criminal matters to the secular
authorities any suggestion that
jehovah's witnesses cover up child abuse
or in any way discourage or frown upon
reporting allegations to the secular
authorities is absolutely false
the independent inquiry into child
sexual abuse is due to report its
findings into religious organizations
including jehovah's witnesses tomorrow
whether their senior members of the
church will act on them is another
matter
jason farrell sky news